Rea righto great columnist Bay Area's
sports figured raid would have some
thoughts about the Raiders making a bold
move bringing in Antonio Brown first
reaction there Rea was what that this
was something that if it hadn't been Jon
Gruden doing it al Davis would have
wanted to do it it was such a it was
such a classic al move in that he
basically sees a great player who has
fallen out with his team and that other
team's more conservative than he would
safety he's too much trouble and then he
would do the deal in a heartbeat
so I think historically this is a
classic Raider deal it's not a recent
Raider deal but it's a classic Raider
deal but it worked for Al Davis at a in
a different time in a different NFL you
know but al Davis would he so he'd make
this move now but we saw these moves
didn't work out later on and Al's tenure
as the owner of the Raiders well but I
wasn't looking after guys who were you
know considered just problems he needed
three agents to back and fill bad teams
and try to teach younger players how to
embrace like the rigors of football and
in each of those cases Randy Moss
Richard Seymour Warren Sapp they had
other ideas and as soon as they got to
Oakland and saw how dysfunctional it was
they said not for me so I think it's
different Antonio Brown is basically
playing to prove a that the Steelers are
fools
which I don't think he needs much help
doing and to that he gets to be the
premier wide receiver for a few more
years because I think that's the other
motivation he has is that how does it
work out how does this become something
great it becomes something great if Jon
Gruden the coach doesn't get in the way
and by that I mean Jon Gruden the coach
is the old-school guy he wants them at
every practice like
fifteen minutes early he wants them at
all the OTAs because that's one of the
things that caused him to fall out with
Khalil Mack yes there was the money but
it was the fact that Mack wouldn't come
to to any team activities until his
contract was done that I think convinced
Rudin early on I'm gonna move this guy I
think if if Antonio Brown comes with the
full work ethic of being the best player
I think Gruden the coach will be okay
with that
Gruden the general manager already loves
the move because he swindled one of the
Raiders longtime arch rivals and when I
say swindled I mean stole naked but if
an Tonio Brown is that all disruptive
and I see no reason why he would be
because his disruptions in Pittsburgh
were for the most part about the fact
that he was ridiculously underpaid as
long as he can you know come to grips of
the fact that he's no longer
ridiculously underpaid I think it'll get
along fine do I think it makes him a
playoff team no they're way too far away
in a lot of other areas and he may lose
interest at that point but for the short
term I think this is gonna be fine who's
the quarterback moving forward when we
get to Vegas who's the quarterback of
the Raiders ooh that's an open one I I
think Gruden and and Derek Carr were up
and down with each other last year I
mean I they wanted to like each other
but I think at times you know Gruden
sort of would go off of him I'm gonna
guess it's not Derek Carr but I don't
think they're gonna get a chance to get
Tyler Murray so I think it might be
whoever's next down the road just
because Jon Gruden is not a guy who's
particularly married to anybody he
inherited I think part of his sort of
inert which is that he wants to clean
out everything that was in the building
before he got there and you saw that he
did it later in the day with Coleco
semele who had been a pretty useful
offensive lineman for them so I I think
that into and by the time they get to
Vegas I don't think it'll be there a car
I can't tell you who it will be though
and I'm pretty sure won't be Ben
Roethlisberger we're talking to Ray
Ratto local vagrant in the Bay Area
joining us Dan Patrick Patrick show I
want to play something to clay Thompson
had to say after the loss to the
suddenly powerful Phoenix Suns last
night get your reaction to it I expect
our crowd to be good morning to it too
like I know it's not the playoffs but
here's our last caller out of Oracle at
least you can stand up if something we
make a good play especially beginning we
need that energy especially this time of
the year it's hard to conjure up energy
every single night because you're
looking for the playoffs not run so we
expect our fans kind of you know bring
that from the jump you can't I mean it's
like us though you can't bring it every
night but still it helps when it doesn't
matter for playing the Suns or the Bucs
whoever it is we need that energy from
them because we feed off that what do
you make of that Ray well having seen
the game they got silly booed last night
for one of the very few times in the
last five years I mean people were
genuinely angry because you I don't care
how good Phoenix has been going lately
you cannot lose to them at home the
night after they played in Portland I
mean if you're in the you can't you
can't do that and you can't expect your
fans to applaud that that said I think
he was more surprised than angry because
you know while the fans in in Oakland
when they're getting a bad performance
from the fellows they tend to get quiet
they don't get tend to get angry so I
think it was more surprised than
anything else because they were horrible
and they've been up and down all year
and really for the last you know year
plus you know there have been nights
when they haven't really fully engaged
with the process and when you're paying
those prices you don't want to be
victimized by you know on they didn't
feel like it tonight oh well my 480
bucks to take me and my kid to the game
sort of went down the toilet so I think
there's a little bit of that and just
the notion that
they really they really believe that
they can turn this on and off last year
they did this year I think some people
are starting to think you know what the
league's better than it was I wonder if
they can I think there's a little bit of
doubt in everybody's mind that you know
that the ride is still going to go on so
I think in a lot of ways there's more
angst this year than there was a year
ago and went again when you stick it up
against the Suns you deserve that I mean
I'm surprised and burn the building down
finish this sentence if the Golden State
Warriors don't win the NBA Finals this
year joël a cub will jump off a tower I
think everything about this year is
predicated on the fact that they win
because next year they go into a new
building with new pricing and kind of a
different fan base that's going to
change more and more within the years to
come I think they are so not prepared
for not winning this that I think it
could be like fundamentally worrisome to
the organization because I think they've
assumed as everybody else has that this
is the best team and nothing but a
catastrophic injury can derail that but
you know Milwaukee's better Toronto is
better Philadelphia is intriguing
you know they're not winning by the same
wide margins they used to they're not
dominating teams like they did in the
first three years of this so I think I
think the signs are there that this
could go off the rails I'm not saying
that it will but I think the signs are
there that it could and if it does
they're gonna go wait a minute who are
we now and I think all of a sudden every
decision they make has a new and weirder
urgency to it yeah I mean I'd have
thought from the beginning that Kevin
Durant is gone you know there was a you
don't have to be a lip reader to
understand what Steve Kerr was saying
about draymond Green that he's you know
bleep and tired of this bleep and stuff
from draymond Green although
drayman's gonna be there but you know as
you move forward
I assume clay stays and why would he
leave and then you got step but you know
Kevin is has always been the outlier
here so I think it'll be different no
matter what whether they win or not
going into that new building but I mean
it's weird because I keep hearing from
people who say that if they don't win
you know Durant will want to stay
because he wants more rings than LeBron
I don't know if I buy that but I don't
know if the rent really knows ultimately
what he wants to do yet but we're not
giving him credit for these rings ray so
it doesn't matter if he stays on for one
more yeah but it's not what you're
giving him it's what he's giving himself
because his view of his place in the
basketball universe is different than
everybody else's and it's gonna be hard
to make the case that in his mind anyway
well I have more rings that's how you
guys keep score if you're not keeping
score that way with me then what are we
doing so I mean I that's interesting me
Durant Durant is it Durant is an odd
duck in a lot of ways because he doesn't
really react the way people think he
will react to a lot of different things
I mean he's been treated with kid gloves
in the Bay Area media wise and still he
turned on the media so you know what
Durant I don't know the the the the
dream on thing is more interesting
because I'm not convinced that Kerr
wasn't referring to the fact that
draymond green cannot take cannot make a
shot anymore
and I think Kerr really likes green as
much as he rotates and as much as they
butt heads they are kind of the same guy
competitively so I said my guess is what
he was saying there was I am so tired of
looking at that shot now I think he said
exactly what everybody has lip-read but
I think the reference probably was to
the family because he was playing
defense well I mean he rebounded but he
cannot put a ball in the ocean and I
have a feeling that that's probably the
underlying key here now if he comes out
too
just oh no I really hate him and I'd
like to subscribe that I might change my
mind at that point but you know ker has
been trying to keep everybody happy all
year long at happy and motivated at a
time when most of them are happy but not
all of them are motivated all the time
ray thanks for joining us as always and
good luck being a local vagrant there
well it as long as the parks are open I
have a place to sleep right thank you
Ray that's a ray Ratto bay area legend
Colin is one of our favorites for more
Dan Patrick show to the audience Channel
239 on Direct TV or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]